[Music]
so welcome to the technical founders
panel this tends to be my favorite talk
a panel session of the whole conference
it's probably the least technical thing
we do here because of you know as you've
noticed there's lots of architectural
diagrams and formulas and machine
learning models and all that other good
technical stuff at the conference all
the rest of the time this is the one
session that we do that's or that's
aimed to be a little bit more business
oriented and I'm a three-time technical
founder a software engineer from the
first bubble and so what I like to do in
this panel is I is I try and imagine me
as a young founder as an engineer and a
young founder and what what did I want
to know then that I don't know that I
didn't know and how did I learn it and
so when I talked to other technical
people it seems that they have often
gone through similar similar problems
maybe different solutions
I think the representative of the other
technical people in the audience who
might be interested in starting
companies as well so this session is
with you guys in mind for those of you
who are thinking about starting a
company who are starting a company
trying to run it better who are starting
your second or your third company
because your first and second company
failed which always happens by the way
90 plus percent of the time so don't
feel bad when I stopped and I realized
how many companies I had started before
the one succeeded and then I realized
there wasn't even a number of companies
it was all the ideas I had that I tried
to get to market even before I kind of
them companies and when I realized I had
failed seven eight times to try to build
something and bring it to market and
only two or three of those have I even
like gotten to the point where even
called them companies I realized how
many failures I had under my belt that
finally brought me to the point where I
felt like I was competent as an engineer
entrepreneur so all that's a big long
intro to say that's why we're here so
I hope you're in the right place does
that resonate at all guys so we're gonna
talk about failing fast and failing
often and we'll try and keep it
light-hearted so I'm gonna have the
panelists introduce themselves
we have ALP Hussain and we'll who's also
our data science track host and they're
just gonna tell us just a little bit
about how they got here and briefly
about the company that they're working
on now yeah so my name is help thanks
for having me this is a really nice
opportunity yeah so I have a PhD in
machine learning and afterwards I set
off to found this company called Farah
labs which builds machine learning
software for the industrial sector so
this is kind of the approach of taking a
very kind of sexy sexy technology
applying it to a very unsexy area so
imagine kind of any kind of
manufacturing plant they're typically
sitting on a lot of data we help them
become more efficient with their own
data so they can reduce their energy
bills they can improve their quality
they can reduce waste and so this got
one kind of untapped area where we found
that machine learning had a very kind of
high value-added proposition I'm Jose
it's great to be here like help I I did
my PhD in machine learning I worked at
Google for a couple of years and then I
was co-founder and chief data scientist
at this personal financial management
app so after that we have started a new
company which is more around organizing
blockchain data and making it available
for different use cases
William Falcon I'm co-founder of
next-gen vast we help high school
students figure out how to pay for
college over text message so we'll pair
you up with the money mentor which is
like your financial adviser and we'll
figure it will help you apply for loans
get your scholarships even tell you
where to go to school and so on
and before this I was working at Goldman
Sachs internal startup they're called
Mark II and then I built about Atos apps
before that so um for my own I guess
those are failures and then the other
ones for clients who hired me to build
their companies yeah and I'm doing a PhD
now and deep learning and reinforcement
learning at NYU as well sometimes you
fail by helping your clients fail but
that's the different kind of transfer
learning so we have PhD PhD at PhD so
first question what business do PhD is
have starting companies sure I could
take that I think it's a great skill set
I think one thing you learned throughout
the process of a PhD is to handle
uncertainty you get very adept at being
able to teach yourself new concepts
quite quickly and adapt to new
information and I think you guys will
agree that that's a skill set that's
useful when you're testing so many
hypotheses as a early-stage company yeah
I guess I'm coming at it you know I did
the company and then started my PhD so I
the similarities that I'm noticing a lot
are the kind of rapid iteration and the
ability to you know to be able to
succeed in your company you have to test
different hypotheses very quickly and
like fail fast or like dig into one and
like really push through it if you like
to think it's gonna work and you also
you always have like viable options of
things you could do but one of them is
probably gonna take too much effort not
give you enough RI so you have to
account balance those things out so the
research mindset is very much like hold
a lot of things constant change one
thing see what happens and do that and
that you kind of need that as well for
your startup I think in general
intellectual depth if you manage not to
let it get in your way is good so
basically I'm running and operating a
business 95 or maybe even more percent
of times as just finding searching
things finding them out but then they're
like 1 or 2 percent or maybe a little
bit more depending on the type of
company that you would need to kind of
get deeper and can't try to like
understand intellectually what's going
on to be able to navigate out of it and
but even though it's a small percentage
it always happens because there's so
many decisions that you end up making so
it helps but I don't find that work
where those like couple of percentage
that you need to you know use that depth
versus just being agile and executing is
and on the money side you have
fellowships you have grants things you
have to apply for and that's very
similar to fundraising yeah good point
so I mean obviously there's all types of
education and life experience and
professional experience that you know
not everyone has a PhD and I don't think
necessarily the message is you have to
have a PhD to serve a company but but
it's very interesting that the iteration
and the experimentation sort of
resonates with you immediately
are there other just speaking about the
academia thing are there other
categories of academics that you see
challenged in starting companies or
there were the particular things in your
experience that you had to sort of
relearn or learn differently where
coming from academia was a was more of a
challenge than a than an asset I'll take
this I think we tend to seek perfection
as academics right we want to polish our
ideas you know look at any kind of
opposition we might have to the ideas
that we're presenting so when we present
scientific ideas it comes from this kind
of defensive skepticism kind of
perspective and I think there simply
isn't that room to do that in a startup
right things cannot be published things
cannot be polished from the get-go you
don't have that luxury so I think that's
maybe one thing yeah it's actually a
great point we had this issue early on
where a lot of my employees would like
want to present something very polished
and we had to say you know what like
just get us a v1 of this because we
can't wait three months for the for you
to like come up with like the thing that
you're like proud to show it's like it's
okay like no one's going to judge
so having that ability to present
something that's not a hundred percent
done is very critical yeah that's a
great point and I saw that in my early
days as an engineer turned founder like
I just was a perfectionist and I wanted
everything to be perfect and just the
concept of like showing the world your
app in draft mode just seemed asinine to
me and that was probably one of the
earliest things that I had to break in
myself was just my own need for
perfection perfectionism and I think we
learned that through either transfer
concepts like MVPs right and the the
startup culture is okaying that we can
launch stuff without it being perfect
but sometimes it's easy to be set in a
acronym but it's hard to actually
internalize so I think that's a key
thing
what were the other challenges and this
might be more you know related to other
areas but what we're what were your
greatest challenges personally in
starting your first company or starting
your last company just any sort of
specific story that was a real hurdle
that you personally had to overcome I
think there's a lot outside of academia
that is governed by okay well I might
imagine is like or described as soft
effects so when you're fundraising you
need to convince people to take a bet on
your company oftentimes the things that
you might rely on to evaluate other you
know things that are very concrete and
technical won't really fly there right
some investors will simply just want
softer signals and that's kind of hard
to get your head around because you know
we typically operate with this method is
better than this other method because it
minimizes this number and that self of
enough exactly I mean before we think
it's self evidence that so therefore
this is better right
you know we should bag trees because
it's clearly the better thing to do I
think that's a bit frustrating yeah I
mean I see the same challenge basically
and kind of taking that demmick side a
little bit you have a lot of ways to be
objective about concepts but while in a
business world even if you find good
mentors that they had a lot of
experience it's really hard to find
objective ways to think about everybody
has their own biases their own
excitements and you kind of need to
understand those subjectivities and kind
of find the objective way to you know be
a successful business and sometimes with
numbers that's more clear but sometimes
someone just asks you I think you need
to your go-to-market should look like
this man there's no clear evidence why
or why not so yeah so I think there are
a billion challenges right and at
different scales as well so you know if
you're an engineer coming into a startup
you have your own like brand of
challenges that you have to overcome in
terms of communication sales like
different skill so you're gonna have to
develop especially if you're gonna be a
founder and on the other personal side
you know most people are likely if
you're not coming from school you're
probably coming from a job that's
probably paying you fairly well you have
a pretty good life so having to take a
huge pay cut and then have to change
your lifestyle and then kind of swallow
that and then be a be okay and but like
you know you have to you have to really
come to answer like soft believe I guess
like you have to believe in yourself
enough that you're willing to take that
financial risk that you're able to
convince other people to work for you to
work with you you're gonna convince
founders sorry investors to invest in
you so it's really if you don't have
that confidence it's not going to work
and when when things get really hard and
all your friends are out there making
money and whatever and you're making I
don't know 50 60 K or whatever you want
to pay yourself it's gonna really really
try you so you have to have to believe
that you're gonna succeed otherwise
you're like 98% for sure gonna fail so
what if what if you're like me and you
just say screw it I don't have any
social skills I don't want to sell
anything to any investors I'm going to
do this all myself the hard way
did any of you bootstrap and not raise
money or did you end up raising money we
bootstrapped for maybe a year or so and
and what was the pros and cons of that I
think hiring is the first thing so it's
always almost always just a founder team
when you're bootstrapping if you can
convince anyone else to help you during
that phase they're doing it either on
the side or part-time or whatnot so once
you raise or you have at least some
revenue coming in such that you can grow
the team and the dynamics immediately
changing also what you can do changes I
would say it depends really to the
business you're thinking about just
experience from b2c bootstrapping is
gonna be tough you just generally the
way you approach b2c is you burn some
marketing money and then you have you
iterate you pivot and that's necessary
so and that may be a reason if you want
to bootstrap you you don't want to kind
of be out there looking for money
thinking b2b it's like building a
product you can walk into your customer
they would tell you why they don't want
it if they don't want and then you can
iterate on bootstrap and that's a kind
of much more viable idea yeah I again
I'm a little bit playing the devil's
advocate because you know clearly you
have to learn how to sell something at
some point in time there's no question
and you know that that's just that's
just reality how did you find maybe
instead of talking about how you found
your first investment because that's a
big sort of nut to crack and sometimes
it takes several tries before you get
that right how did you find your first
customers like what did that look like
because often times it can be easier to
find customers before you find money
since the money wants you to presumes
that you have the customers or wants to
see them first anyway in many cases how
did that look for you guys so for my
case my co-founder was working on our
company a bit before I joined her and it
was really kind of experimenting with
those ideas and I mean she took a few
different approaches
- basically going into schools and
trying to speak to people face to face
right so doing customer discovery and
then once we kick that off into high
gear then we literally have people on
the ground that we were paying to go so
yeah I mean going into high schools and
acquiring their users so so it was a
massive ground game just like
glad-handing talking to people meeting
I'm are L yeah exactly going to where
they're at
literally cool I think both of the
efforts that I had I was the customer I
kind of started thinking about I need
this and I was out there doing it and
then I thought well if there are more
people like me needing this and there's
a team that we can build it and deliver
on it and when you are your own customer
you have a lot more understanding of
course you have also biases if you are
not the typical customer then you're
building it for like a small niche but
it gives you a very good understanding
of what are the needs yeah it also
removes the need for you to feel like
you're selling - this is the y
combinator trick right don't worry about
how big the itch is you're scratching
just make sure it's your itch because if
it's your itch you understand the ins
and outs of it you you're passionate
about solving it you quickly like it
into conversations where even as an
engineer you don't feel like you're
selling because you're just talking
about how you salt your edge and so it's
a really natural way for us to overcome
our own sales and marketing challenges
is to make sure that you're focusing on
a pain and a problem that you really
have instead of picking one from the
grab bag of things that you think
somebody would invest in it also helps
with hiring or like getting your
co-founders if if they have the same
problem they'll just buy it you don't
even need to explain why yeah cool so do
you all have co-founders or did you
decide to go it alone what does that
look like yeah I have co-founders I
think it helps especially if it's your
first time starting a company having
that sounding board being able to kind
discuss ideas it's very quickly yeah I
found it to be a huge positive yeah it's
a lonely world so co-founders
for sure at least your first company
after that you probably have a bunch of
advice or some people you can rely on as
well so that's a other Treat trick no
one tells you founders usually have like
a whole staff of advisors to help you
like I'm not a professional when I
started I wasn't a professional CTO but
then I hired a few CTO sis advisors and
I helped out right so this also goes to
your question earlier what's an I guess
something that's a technical founder
what would you do I to like avoid
selling and all this like I would just
hire CEO like go or get a co-founder who
is who is like the perfect sales person
like MBA type all that who like really
want to own that because once you go
fundraise once you go do partnerships
and everything else like someone will
have to own that so like you don't have
to be the person to do it yeah good good
point our keynote this morning Baron
Schwartz he's the co-founder or I think
the founder actually if it cortex he had
no co-founder that I know of
but he was able to step aside at some
point and find a CEO to help grow the
business because you know he I think
made himself do it early on but then
really wanted to get to the point where
he was able to scale in a different way
and so that helps yeah sometimes you
have to try and solve your own problems
but sometimes you just need other people
to help I want to dig into the
mentorship thing because that was key
for me as well did you build an advisory
board did you find your friends with
MBAs to like give you advice like what
forms did that take early on for me I
mean my you know my philosophy I guess
you know to try to boil it down through
like a simple sentence and question it's
like who are the best people in the
world at something because I'm not those
things and I want to find that person
and then hire them as my advisor right
and a lot of times that's equity you
give them equity and you know if you
have to sell them on your idea as well
but if they're passionate they will help
you out but you know if you want to
really kill it at marketing go higher go
look at I don't know some Google or
Facebook whatever find the people who
are really doing well there and try to
get them to be your advisors on that on
that side yeah that was probably the
first time I learned to sell anybody my
idea because I couldn't sell it to a
customer
I couldn't sell it to ABC but I sold it
to what who became a friend from Intel
who was building a similar product like
inside that company and when he saw a
passion I was about the thing he agreed
to help me and I this is before I could
raise money but I made it I sold a
friend essentially and I got him to back
me and he was in my deck and he was part
of my advisory board and that was a very
very small start to finding that kind
like learning that I could passionately
sell that idea yeah and they'll bring
relationships so that there's another
good point so though it's kind of like a
chicken and the egg problem so you
cracked it by bringing the advisors to
give you more legitimacy then you go the
use out to raise money I think another
thing that happens with early stage
investors is that they often recognize
the need for this advice as well so our
lead investors for our seed round Bowery
Capital almost exclusively works with
technical founders and to complement
that they have staff members who help
with sales and marketing and HR which
are typically things that technical
founders have not done before so you can
also find that kind of advice built into
the startup ecosystem through investors
or through these kind of informal
advisors that you can go seek out yeah
it's the best way to get great people
work with you because it's just designed
that way and a lot of people I have
never found someone I randomly reached
out on LinkedIn that I have questions I
would like to talk to you about
something and to say no so I mean
sometimes they don't read the messages
that's different but and some of those
people that they start kind of
understanding or they start helping you
to you know grow your idea more and
better it's very natural to engage them
and incentivize them so definitely
advisors yeah excellent
LinkedIn is an amazing tool and
as much as cold outreach you know scares
those of us who are technical it can be
a powerful powerful thing when you see
people start to respond to your messages
and actually start to offer your help
it's quite remarkable
yeah and that's if you know that now
before you go start a company if you're
working somewhere like take your
managers get them to like you now so
that when you leave they can still be
there for you so my MD at Goldman is
still one of my advisors right now and
like you can open up a lot of doors
right and so wherever you go work
definitely make that network because
they will facilitate things for you
later
excellent excellent points so let's
shift a little bit more to the data side
since this is a data conference after
all you're working in manufacturing
you're doing blockchain analytics and
you were doing conversationally I that's
for for high school students with money
money management right yeah so what's
like were their key ways that you
thought about the data aspect of your
product was that meaningful to you when
you were building our first things or
was that was that an accessory or a
benefit of being successful like how did
you how do you think about that I guess
I can start I mean it's it was a big
kind of hypothesis for us because the
manufacturing space is largely closed to
us kind of regular people right like we
just take for granted that there is
steel available to manufacture all these
things and there is wood available to
manufacture everything else you know
there's energy you know all these things
we take for granted so the question is
what do these establishments look like
and how much data do they have and what
does that data look like so for us it
was kind of a critical hypothesis that
we rent went around investigating
different sectors and you know looking
for evidence and there is indeed a large
variation of data readiness across
different sectors and that's something
that was part of our kind of discovery
process but you probably realized as
well that they didn't even have the data
set that you wanted to build for them so
your product are you putting centers
sensors on machines we are not no well
so what's your approach so the
assumption is that there are sectors
that are already a bit more data ready
so they already have sensors installed
or
the equipment that they use to
manufacture whatever their manufacturing
comes with sensors and so they're
already sitting on data there's a whole
nother segment of startups are working
on let's go in these sectors they're a
little bit more behind the curve and
sell them hardware so that they can
become this kind of like Internet of
Things equipped next generation factory
so the opportunity for you is to help
the client utilize the data that they
had in more efficient ways that's right
god that was our kind of proposition
that's what we explored got it
hüseyin well we are we are a data
company so but to kind of as it were
what does that mean
so we we package and provide data so
data is our product so just as a general
comment and around like why I ended up
time doing what we are doing if your
data scientist or data engineer you have
data related skills there they're
basically two there is one way to
monetize that and that's like to apply
to some data so now either that data is
owned by a company which has other
operations other processes that is
generating that data and then you need
to go work for them or like be a
consultant from outside or you find the
data that's out there it's public and
not many people have looked into it and
you package it you find some insights
from it and you sell the data so I've
gone the second path after like my
experience with other businesses so and
I think as data scientist you want or
data engine you want to see where the
date is who owns it and what is the
potential value coming out of it and is
it kind of looked into a lot or not many
people have really digged into it for us
from the beginning is definitely
probably more opinionated about this and
Kelly my co-founder I wanted to build
everything that we did on machine
learning right in the future so you know
we're thinking if you're gonna build a
new bank like if we can start from the
ground up how do we do it and can we set
it up right now to be correct so that us
we scale we have all the tools there so
I hate cleaning data so everything that
we did from like day one was just to
make sure that every
thing that we took in was structured and
design in a way that would make data
science and machine learning a lot
easier and to the state still that way
and so every single we have analytics
and metrics and everything's in real
time because of that but you know for a
lot of our models the the neural
networks specifically which are doing a
lot of their conversational stuff it
takes a lot of data to to train those
models so we didn't have that data for
like a year so during that year we
basically spent our time locking down
our business metrics so that we can
track our okrs and make sure that we're
on track and missus health and all that
so that's all generated as meta meta
data from your operations and I think
even if you're gonna do a machine
learning company you need to have that
first because you like this is a
research site where like you need to
know how you're driving the business
before you can make any decisions about
it and see the impact of that and so
what about so will you got to the point
where you guys were generating your own
novel data set that was the byproduct of
your yeah is that fair
we're having chats so people are texting
us and at some point we had enough
conversations and enough text messages
to where we could do our own right but
even in machine learning even if you're
doing new on that were even deep
learning you know you can do transfer
learning so if you're doing a computer
vision I guess application you can
always use pre trained models now for an
LPS of like a few weeks ago there's this
crazy model that you can use transfer
learning on so there there are new
techniques we can take other data sets
and then fine-tune them on yours and
that you have a really good great model
so is that emerging as a meaningful
answer to the cold start problem yep yep
and serbs can get super creative about
doing these things but I think transfer
learning is the way to kind of crack
that Apple for AI companies it's like
how all the autonomous vehicle companies
in Silicon Valley we're training their
early models on gta3 ok I mean this is
the thing like it happened until they
got enough data where they could write
you know not play inside the video game
anymore yeah that's you know
self-driving cars like that's how
they're doing a lot of that you can't
you can't go crash a thousand cars just
to figure out that you shouldn't turn
left there so you you build simulators
and you do it there so is this is this
concept is this philosophically like
changing the ball game for small
startups that don't have access to all
the training data
of Google Microsoft or Amazon or is that
still does that still represent sort of
a existential problem for small startups
who need to Train stuff I guess it
depends on the domain but I think that
small startup chernow can compete with
Google and Facebook because most of the
ice open-source anyways all the papers
are public so the data set you know I
don't think our companies are competing
on the AI itself they're competing on
the data set now that's your moats and
that's what we should protect but
there's enough data and open source
stuff that you can bootstrap something
jump start it and then collect your own
data yeah and you know your I guess you
have less restrictions I'm like a Google
and Facebook where all the attentions on
them like Cambridge analytic and all
this other stuff right so you just have
a little bit more flexibility what do
you think you saying well as a start-up
I mean there's always that fear that big
companies are not good for you but I
think there's a gap and there's clear if
you find a problem that you're solving
is adding the value those platforms
Google Amazon Microsoft they are just
they have done a lot of work and they
give you free almost free products so if
in 90's or even early 2000s you wanted
to build a company you needed a server
room and you needed some people just to
keep that up for you now you can go on
google cloud and have that for free they
give you some free credit that you
literally have that server room who
would have costed you some startup money
so and they are not your competitors if
you kind of look at think about the
problem you're solving that they're
basing infrastructure are helping you
and then you're adding there may be the
intellectual concepts on top of the
problems you're solving or the
operations or processes that they will
never get into doing opening of the
thoughts on data novelty yeah I think
it's a it's very specific I think the
the thoughts that were raised are
spot-on in our case there is kind of no
data available
there's no data sharing that happens and
so when we sell our software to
different customers there is nothing in
there that we have learned from any
other customer because we couldn't have
gotten that first customer if that
weren't the case if they knew that we
were taking their data and using that
for you know building software that
grant sell to their competitors or
anything like that so I think it's
interesting that there is you know a
spectrum there there's machine learning
that an AI that you kind of need this
data to get off the ground and then
there's a whole nother branch of
machinery that's kind of based on domain
expertise and you know strong models and
you know you know Bayesian techniques
that work well without having seen data
and that actually can be applied in
these situations when you have no access
to data which is what we're yeah great
point there's a continuum right there's
there's unstructured public data
there's semi structured data there's
structured private data which can
sometimes be shared across customers and
the right use cases right there's all
kinds of different options it reminds me
that company checker in San Francisco
that started to offer background check
service as an API to onboard
uber and lyft drivers who wanted to sign
up fast and nubra had to they had to
have a third party validate the
background checks well all this data has
been available publicly forever but the
companies that were managing it were so
screwed up that they couldn't return
around results fast enough so checker
just got access to all this public data
structured it better stuck in an API and
became this super fast-growing company
on the backs of uber and lyft and they
just found public datasets that were out
there and were better about updating it
keeping a current structuring it and
turning around like requests in their
API calls and that was the business but
it's public dataset so there's there's
lots of opportunities and data that
don't necessarily and you're generating
your own immensely valuable novel data
set that's sort of the byproduct of
consumer success but that's not every
data company either that's only a few in
the world so I think there's a lots of
sea of opportunities in between which it
seems like you guys would agree with
what's the problem with AI for
everything like if I want to go start
pji tomorrow what's the problem with
that approach so I see a ISO way to
solve a problem I guess I don't want to
use it as like oh have this fancy to let
me go find a problem for it so I see the
opportunities you know maybe that's a
like if you want to publish and you know
develop new algorithms maybe that's
academic like yeah you could just do
that because you don't necessarily care
about an application per se just like
maybe the novelty of it
but if you're trying to create a company
you need to produce value for someone so
you really should just be looking at the
problem and if you can solve it using
machine learning better and more
efficiently then that's a tool you can
use but I wouldn't go the other way I
guess I I think it even hurts us at
times so there's so much hype around AI
and and and what AI can do and what the
next revolution is going to be in all
these different fields that you know
oftentimes customers can have very
different understandings of what's
actually possible now and what might be
possible you know five ten years down
the road so I've seen both sides of that
going so there's two bums in San
Francisco and they're talking in the
street and one says hey I started an AI
company yesterday and the other one says
AI company Y and the first bump says
valuation hype yeah don't all laugh at
once think about your questions by the
way because I'm clearly getting tired of
asking questions so we're gonna go to
the audience in just a minute you wanted
to jump in yeah so uh on the AI company
so when I say when I when I say yeah I
guess what I'm more talking about
because maybe some more my research but
deep learning reinforcement learning
those kind of techniques right and like
a lot of Bayesian networks and Bayesian
deep learning as well so everything's
getting mixed up in there and for I
think though they're interesting new
like when a new technology comes out it
opens up new opportunities before deep
learning and reinforcement learning
we weren't great at modeling raw signals
like images or sound or texts like
directly and now for example with deep
learning you can take Ross
waves and literally translate that into
someone speaking or another answer or
text word that was really hard to do
before I think we weren't great at it we
could do a decent job I'm not amazing at
it now with these new techniques it
opens up a whole new opportunities so
automating call centers I don't know
Texas speech that the thing that Google
did a few months ago right so so many
opportunities that just weren't feasible
before because we now can understand
these inputs a lot a lot better are we
are we doing deep learning well on the
mobile yet it's the attention flow port
is that working well or where are we at
on that yeah I think a lot of your
phones are running some certain y'all
network yeah definitely
well today the point around the eye yes
there is hype yes there is evaluation
concepts but it shouldn't stop you from
thinking what is the take technology
frontier and why AI is hyped yes it is
hyped but let's just think about it and
of course there is the marketing the
whole AI as used as a trademark but then
there's science of it there are two
different concepts but it's it's
interesting to see how AI also
practically eye has evolved I think in
seventies people at MIT who were trying
to build AI they ended up building pcs
so and if you think about it it is
intelligence for you to like type
something and something happens that
would have needed more of you know human
intelligence and work to like work with
computers before that so everything we
do that makes that interface easier is
some sort of AI so as long as there's an
understanding and we know we are solving
a problem I think it is fine it just
needs to be doing it excellent
there's one final thing on on the I
guess model selection part of it so
something that I see a lot is you know
and you know you see some finance and
that makes sense but I think in the data
science worlds there's this kind of a
version to deep learning like neural
networks mainly because they're finicky
to train on every
that makes sense for a lot of things but
it's also sometimes you have to pick the
right tools for the right job and a lot
of times neural networks are not the
best job that the best tool for
something but sometimes they are and
people still don't want to use them when
they are the best tool so like I
remember there was someone was talking
about like I think it was sound and they
were trying to use other types of
methods but the best state of the art
right now is the neural network so kind
of not doing that basically kills a lot
of time if you're doing a start-up for
example so trying to pick the right tool
but not over optimize it what is that
predisposition against deep learning
like what do you think that comes from
and maybe it's kind of died down a bit
but it was I think around you know the
black box concept so not being able to
look inside the models and to some
extent that's still true today but we
have a lot more ways of explaining
models right and you know there's a
there's Jelena Kunz who everyone I'm
sure knows and he has he has a great
phrase which is like you know if you
have like a random forest is giving it
like 40 50 percent accuracy on your data
set I think and this isn't a business
application and I give you anyone know
where that gives you 90 percent even if
you can't understand that like that's a
lot of money for you not to take that
model right and so a lot of times people
will kind of at that point switch and
say yeah okay fine we'll use this other
model so I don't know so let's go to the
audience for some questions you guys
have a burning question for the
panelists to be up a microphone it's
right yeah someone hadn't sorry of that
microphone
hey guys hello okay I have a question
about finding customers how do you go
about finding early customers who are
willing to try out a product that sucks
right now or doesn't exist right right
at the very early stages of your company
I mean who's doing but you're doing be
the baby I'm doing b2b and you can't
just go and knock on a you know
chemicals manufacturing plant they won't
let you in so relationships are the best
right so as much as it might seem again
this touches upon the kind of soft side
of things networking is huge going to
events where you think your customers
are going to be talking to them again
building those relationships will open
doors so at least in the b2b world where
at least my customer segment is seems
completely and accessible you can still
kind of work the networking dynamic to
form meaningful relationships and then
that will open up doors so that's how we
did it yeah for b2c I think the bars hi
so you customers really expect things to
work really well so the trick is not to
build something super complex just go
about something that you can build
quickly and have a be one of even if you
don't have all the features and launch
that and then get your product out there
as fast as possible I think people want
to spend a long time trying to get the
best thing so you know there are product
pipelines like you know think that we
have right now that's live if you were
to use our service it's not something
that we came up with like years ago this
is something that evolved right and the
v1 if something is completely different
from the V five or six of it so that
that's just how you evolved and that's
like the funding rounds help you get
there as well engaging some of you if
you're in a case that you have b2 BN
they're hard to like you can't just go
find them and just talk to them
routinely you can engage them as
advisors they might not be willing to
buy your product today but they might be
willing to tell you what you can do to I
mean they see the elements are there and
you're just missing them you know some
5% details that will
what they want how do you know the time
is right it's by the saying it's a
version of the same question that was
asked how do you find your first
customers right because I think the
point is you have to start hallway
testing whether your hallway testing on
LinkedIn or you know talking to your
friends or work accompanies but I think
ultimately you want to find the point
where somebody lights up about your idea
your solution to their problem first of
all they understand what the hell you're
talking about when you say do you have
this problem you're like yes I have that
problem because people know they have
the pain and then the second most
valuable thing is when your solution
actually represents something they
haven't already tried to solve their own
pain then you know you're onto something
but at least in my experience from a
beauty perspective it just takes a lot
of conversations to ountry cure self
from thinking that you have an idea that
represents a pain that someone else
wants solved because you're the most
optimistic person as the entrepreneur
and you have to you have to uncheck
yourself by talking to lots of people
who actually have the same problem and
are actually open to trying your
solution and it's a process but it takes
it comes with practice at least with my
experience I don't know if you guys
would agree I agree I agree I think one
thing to add there is that you know you
can't extrapolate from you know one data
point but you can draw a line between
two so the more you kind of train
yourself to pattern do pattern
recognition
I talked to you know five customers all
five of them seem to have this other
pain point that seems relevant to what I
thought their pain point was but
slightly different but they're all
talking about this other thing right so
then you need to qualify that do they
actually know what they're talking about
are they just following some you know
hype or some buzz words or is this
actually a pain point so you start
qualifying that and you know comes down
to a gut feeling at the very earliest
stage I think you can want to fight
things a little bit better once you have
some of them to me you have some
expertise in the space but if you're
talking about launching right that needs
to you will never have sufficient
evidence to do that in a very like
comfortable way I would say and maybe
won't seem to be careful a lot of people
will tell you this is an amazing product
and this is great and until somebody
hasn't paid you the money or hasn't done
their basically the part that makes them
your customer that doesn't mean much
they are ways to improve on your surveys
to just get a better gauge but the best
ways to you know it's it's every time
it's just a lot of stress now like what
people get by just for people like this
and that drives you to improve every day
and everyone every feedback you get so
it's just part of the process you know
you're never sure and even then the
first person buys it you're like well
what the second person buy it is it
going to keep continuing so it's I think
it's the process to just be in it and
improve and grow yeah so I guess
everyone here is familiar with data
science I can use this analogy never
know secreting disentis right so I hope
it's not crazy idea imagine you have a
valley right and you try to get to the
bottom of that and you're going to
sample you're going to take a little bit
of data samples you're gonna get to the
bottom I think you're the answer to your
question is exactly that how do you know
you're right you don't you literally
start it somewhere in that valley and
you want to get to the bottom of that
and to optimize that's literally the
whole process of building the startup
you're gonna take a month there are a
few people sample some data figure out
what direction should move to next and
pivot your product until you get to that
valley and you're basically gradient
accenting through the startup
and that's how I think like I think
about it at least so maybe I have a
great hypotheses and a great prior to
start me somewhere but until I validate
it with people and they move based on
their feedback and continue doing that
process I'm not gonna actually get to
the the product market fit which is like
the crucial point in the startup I think
the biggest challenge there are to for
us engineers is you just want to go out
and start building something and you can
do that it's gonna take a lot of time
and it's gonna take you a lot longer to
figure out if you built the right thing
when you finally emerge from your coding
cave and you show the proposed client
that thing it's amazingly easy to test
ideas with a landing page and a
presentation deck and it's not our
strong skills as engineers necessarily
to be a communicator like that but it's
amazing how many coding cycles you can
save if you would just put pen on paper
and learn to communicate it's going to
teach you a few sales skills a few
communication skills but if you can get
someone to buy into the problem and the
solution that you've articulated in a
two-page PowerPoint you're gonna save
yourself blood sweat tears and a lot of
cash from your bank account by not going
out and building at first now sometimes
that doesn't work we'd want to just
build stuff and get out there were
engineers and that can work too but you
just have to realize that there's lots
of shortcuts to validating your ideas
that don't involve coding and that's a
hard thing to learn as a engineer it's
also scared because you're gonna get
rejected a ton people gonna say no and I
think that's why people don't want to do
that and I think to your point about
monetization try to monetize as soon as
you can because that's also when people
gonna start saying no to you so I think
hindsight we waited too long to do that
right like we should have start a long
time ago but as soon as you start really
trying to get people to pay for your
product that's where rubber hits the
road and that's where you're gonna know
you have a business or not so just get
to as quickly as possible and it's also
very easy these days right you can put
up a website quickly and you can imagine
you have the product build a website you
can always say well we are testing or
like we disclose it that it's not
product it's not ready but you can put
the concept out there with really makes
you nothing just your time and putting
there takes life
we're great one more one more question
then we'll break here this is more for
the founder and you guys what do you
think of work-life balance and if it
exists or what are your thoughts and how
do you maintain yourself and your
work-life balance
personally I'll take this question I
think for us yeah so I have very strong
opinions about this there is a book
called we work written by the two
founders of a software company that you
might know they produce this piece of
software called Basecamp and they kind
of give anti advice to this workaholic
American kind of culture of working
hundred hours a week and whatnot so like
I could people out of my office at 6
p.m.
we want to hire people who have
interesting exciting lives outside of
work because then they don't waste their
time at work so I mean I'm two and a
half years into this startup and I don't
think I've pulled more than one or two
you know 50 plus hour weeks so it can be
done it's just a matter of you know
discipline and culture so I those are
employees
future employees so yeah I'm gonna have
to go the opposite way on that one I
think if you want work-life balance then
go retire at Google or Facebook like
that's what I told people when they were
you know when I was hiring and
everything else it's like if you if you
want to live a pretty nice life and just
chill and do that then go work at a
company to me that's like retirement if
you want to be a founder and your
employees can take their time and your
employees should not be burnt out but
it's a founder if you're about to give
up a job that's paying a ton of money to
do something you better make it work out
because everything's on the line for you
so you know I I personally try to
balance
I do take some time off and everything
but I will say that if you're not
working hard someone else is working
hard and they're trying to get to do
what you're doing
so but you as a manager and a founder
you have to keep your team from burning
out so you have to put limitations on
them as well if that makes sense but you
don't get that luxury awesome hot button
that was a great one to end on we're
gonna carry this into the happy hour um
thank you guys for the amazing opinions
and and even more the experience thank
you
thank you for having us
[Applause]
[Music]